The Lone Ranger finally hits the big
screen in the form of a movie that's
about as long as the Dark Knight
necessary let's review this
The Lone Ranger
so the Lone Ranger stars Armie Hammer as
The Lone Ranger and Johnny Depp is the
Indian that's the will is a Native
American and PC terms but they call him
Indian in this movie is it okay to call
him an Indian it's just it's what they
said in a tiny how he plays the Indian
Tonto so now the Lone Ranger and Tonto
team up to take out the bad guys now we
have our adventure that's about two and
a half hours long but four movies two
and a half hours long I have no problem
with it as long as I walk out going oh
yeah totally justified being two and a
half hours was the Lone Ranger justified
I don't think so Armie Hammer plays The
Lone Ranger he's this lawyer he's not a
gunslinger he's not a warrior actually
he's really passive he's like I don't
like guns you know guns are bad how
about bringing them in and having them
on trial and truth and justice which at
a point in the movie you're like you're
just being naive and unbelievable when
people are shooting up the barn you
can't just walk out into the open and be
like in the name of the law and hold up
your badge thinking they're not gonna
shoot at you which of course does happen
it made me step out of the movie just be
like I am not buying this guy and now we
have Captain Jack Sparrow as Tonto I
call him Captain Jack Sparrow because he
plays Captain Jack Sparrow I'm a Johnny
Depp fan I love Johnny Depp as Captain
Jack Sparrow but Johnny Depp has been
Captain Jack Sparrow in so many things
that are not Pirates of the Caribbean is
getting obnoxious I suppose he's not
completely like Captain Jack Sparrow
because the grammar and his sentence
structure is like a cliched Indian at
that time no Kemosabe big explosion
barring but it's still Captain Jack
Sparrow and these two never really
clicked together in the movie for me I
don't know if it's because Johnny Depp
and Armie Hammer don't have good
chemistry or it's just because the
script is shotting doesn't a lot for it
all I know is about halfway through this
movie no spoilers here but this is this
is relevant they're both buried up to
their neck in dirt they're gonna die
alone Ranger gets out of that situation
and he leaves
Tonto there he doesn't say I'm gonna
come back he's like pyrius later the
only reason he came back for Tonto is
because Tonto knew where they had to go
so he needed but if Tonto didn't have
that information he would have left him
there to die
okay Lone Ranger you're a pacifist you
don't shoot people because you believe
it's bad but you're gonna leave a guy
buried up to his neck in the ground with
scorpions around him to die slowly in
the Sun
that makes you an it would be
less of an if you took a gun and
shot him in the teeth and killed him
that way leading people to die slower
than they would die if he shot them
doesn't make you a better guy one thing
that did work in this movie for me
William Fichtner bullying Fichtner is a
good actor it's fun to see him play
villains because he just has so much fun
playing villains dude made Dr angry he
was awesome in that movie and he does
his best Jonah Hex impersonation in this
movie plays a villain and he has fun
doing it and it's fun to watch him do it
is he an original villain do you walk
out of there going whoa dude stole the
show because he was so original now the
dude steals the show because it shows a
mess
shredder different story william
fichtner 'he's a lot of things Oroku
Saki not one of them although I guess
he's gonna be thanks Michael Bay Tonto
his story was interesting enough the
parts in the movie that made me go okay
now I'm getting invested in the story
it's all the Tonto storylines that was
actually really good a couple of small
moments shoehorned into this two and a
half hour long movie another thing that
was cool like cartoony cool yeah but a
lot of this movies kind of cartoony but
at this point you kind of fall back into
it because the Lone Ranger theme kicks
on is altered and independent at the
time and all the actions going down and
you just kind of you fall into it you're
like okay I'll watch this part of the
cartoon and enjoy this because of the
song otherwise known as a song and
return fire that plays when you get the
flag and you're going back to your base
and this movie does play that up among
all of the cartoony happening that
song makes it all fun the two hours 15
minutes leading up to it it's just it's
a bit messy friends I mean you could
have shortened this up and focus the
story people died and so now army
hammers like oh I need vengeance we're
not vengeance justice because I don't
shoot people in the face but this clicks
in his brain about an hour into this
movie you're like that could have
happened in the first half an hour and
been just as relevant another thing I
found weird I get it because this is a
way to tell the story is that the story
of The Lone Ranger is being told to this
kid kind of like The Princess Bride how
the grandfather is telling Fred Savage
about the Princess Bride
same thing really in this movie but it's
not it doesn't do anything for the story
all I see is a thing that can be taken
out of this movie to make the movie a
more manageable and logical length in
the end for the Lone Ranger you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day
yep already forgot I just do with that
rating in like five days so what do you
guys think of Johnny Depp and his Johnny
Depp isms I want a bad mouth the guy cuz
guys a good actor are you like alright
yeah Jack Sparrow I get it it's fun but
it's all you can do
or do you have no problem with it you
love it every time he does it whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more